- [Gary] If you want it,
you got to do it.
Too many people
talking and not executing.
("I Can't Leave You
Alone" by Elmer Abapo)
(jet engine)
Heading to Facebook.
Still hustlin'.
You know, good old fashioned
10 hours in the
air for 15 hours of
commuting for a one hour talk.
But Facebook is a platform
that we continue to
triple down on and trying
to really think a lot more about
impact versus volume this year.
This one talk, I have a bunch
of important meetings seven,
eight different meetings in
New York but this one I feel
will have a lot
of impact 'cause
I get in front of
a lot of people that
I need to and it will be
a spark and a gateway drug
for us to collect it.
Now that I have
the Office of the CEO
I can scale those opportunities.
So just trying to
be much more strategic
about every fuckin' minute.
You should watch.
Oh you don't need to.
I'm gonna post it. So.
- [DRock] People are
scared to always do that.
They always try to
overthink the ideas.
- People try to
overthink everything.
- [DRock] Yeah, I think
that's a very valid point.
- That I just
came up for biz dev.
- [DRock] Yeah, and
then we're doing it--
- Here's the key.
- [DRock] and then we fail.
- Here's actually,
that's it. You nailed it.
I don't give a fuck if
Biz Dev Sundays works or not.
It felt right at the time, we're
gonna execute it right now,
I'll get some dividends
from it anything from zero to
life-changing, right?
VaynerToys, lost money.
Wine Library TV,
changed my career, right?
Actually the more I think about
it like the amount of things
that I, you know,
VaynerToys doesn't work.
Wine Library TV
changes my career.
I'm trying to
think, Jesus Christ.
Vchat didn't work.
#AskGaryVee Search Engine,
crushing and it could be way
bigger we just haven't
done a good job promoting it.
(bell dings
multiple times)
Yeah, I mean I think the reason
most people are losing is
'cause they're scared of losing.
That's the punchline.
I just don't give a crap.
I just don't care about
other people's opinions on my
entrepreneurial ventures.
Everybody else does.
Just 99% does.
("I Can't Leave You
Alone" by Elmer Abapo)
- It'll be awesome.
Even though I only spent
a half hour taking the
garbage out this morning.
- That's what we do, right?
- Right.
- I take the garbage out.
- You have to.
- CEO takes out the garbage
and closes the biggest deal.
That's the game.
- Exactly.
You got to do everything.
- What's your name?
- Johnny.
- Johnny, thanks man.
What I'm doing
now in DM is insane.
Hitting people in DM.
Think I'm gonna change.
I think, listen to this, I'm
usually pretty headstrong,
I think there's been four,
five suggestions of calling it
Crushing It and then
leave Crushed It for the end.
- [DRock] I like that.
- I'm probably gonna do that.
- I'm being sold on it.
- [DRock] I like
that better because--
- It's in the middle, yeah.
Just got a DM from somebody.
It says, "I love your DailyVee.
"It made me respect
where I am in the journey.
"I never want to take any step
or victory for granted and just
"getting my hands dirty."
It's fun, right?
'Cause a lot of kids think
they've made it or a lot of kids
haven't made it yet and they
watch this and they don't take
the fucking 15 hour
commute for one meeting that
they think is strategic.
They don't grind.
And putting in perspective what
it takes that has always been my
biggest goal with this.
60 Second Club, don't forget
to like the photo as well.
Too many of you just posting.
We're checking now.
No cheating, mother fuckers.
(R&amp;B music)
(audience applause)
They know me.
This is my song.
Love it.
Thank you.
Somebody did their homework.
That's my jam.
Couple things to
address right away.
First, I want to thank my mom
for that first
bio that you read.
Number two, I don't
think I'm provocative at all.
That will be
the basis of my talk.
I actually think when people say
I'm provocative or a futurist or
disruptive I genuinely
believe that I'm the
most practical of all.
I always start meeting with my
clients listened you to be in
the no business
instead of the yes business.
So we show you shit, you
need to say "Oh my God, no."
You can't put
(censored) pics on the video.
Not that's not adjective
is isn't on brand
or that color.
This magical on brand
shit is the funniest thing
I've ever seen my life.
It is literally, literally
the thing people love the most
'cause again it's
all they've only got.
I mean do you know what a brand
manager in America looks like?
They went to business
school, they're P&amp;L driven.
Their most fun is hanging out
with you when they get to do
the creative thing and the only
leverage they have is to say,
"Not funny enough."
(audience laughter)
So they play that card.
It has nothing to do
with the reality of business.
Guys, for every "Just Do It"
and every MasterCard priceless,
tons of all time great pieces
of content hit the cutting room
floor because the
creative director came in and
said you know what?
We've only got an hour
and a half so instead four,
let's pitch these two.
He fucked up.
That third one would've been it.
Or they come in with
those two and the person
picks the other one.
It's just not
efficient in a 2017 world,
so yes if I can get them there
and they're
scared shitless of this.
But unlike you guys where you
have to pander to the situation,
I literally don't give a
fuck if we lose the business.
I mean it.
The only reason we've been
able to cut through is I'm like,
"Cool, see ya."
(audience laughter)
Like I don't know.
We have to do it our way.
There's no ROI positive for me
to fucking do it the other way.
Nobody watches a
fucking television commercial,
nobody on Earth.
(audience laughter)
When are we gonna put
common sense into the equation?
The best deal in
the world in marketing,
the Super Bowl ad
'cause it is event viewing.
The worst deal, whether
it's the Oscars or Grammys,
I don't even pay attention.
I don't even allow myself to
spend one second to do this
homework because it
means nothing for my future but
whatever the second most
expensive commercial is let's
call it the
Oscar or the Grammys,
the worst deal in advertising.
Nobody's watching a
commercial during the Oscars.
It's not, it's not
event driven watching.
Everybody is commenting
on the person's dress.
We lack common
sense in our industry.
Bless you.
We lack common
sense in this industry.
The end.
(audience laughter and applause)
Here's what I know and
this is what pisses me off.
I go and do these
things, I go to Cannes,
I get on.
I'm part of a panel with the
creative director of this horse
shit and creative director
of that horse shit and
creative director
of this horse shit.
I do my thing, they all
team up with bullshit data
and then that's it.
Then we go to the Carlton at 3
o'clock in the morning and drink
rosé and you pump them with a
couple bottles of rosé and they
come over and be
like, "You're right."
(audience laughter)
I promise you this one thing,
if people's lives depended on it
the way I marketed for my family
business and I had
to feed my family,
if people's lives
depended on these decisions,
they wouldn't be
doing what they're doing.
I really appreciate the
work you guys are doing.
I hope I get to cross
paths with a bunch of you.
(audience applause)
("Warhols" by Truth City)
Alright, that was successful.
Now back to the airport.
2:15, yeah easily.
We're gonna be
there in what, 25 minutes?
Yeah, easy.
Cruising.
Good, move all calls.
Did you just see what I did?
Touch my ear,
did you catch that?
- [DRock] No.
(tape rewinding)
- Guys, that's how much I feel
that these are a part of me now.
I had to touch my ear
to see if they were in.
(DRock laughs)
That's crazy, right?
- [DRock] That is crazy.
- That was very weird.
- [DRock] What are you,
three weeks in?
- I mean robots are taking over.
I'm just trying
to tell everybody.
("Warhols" by Truth City)
We made it out early, so now I'm
catching an earlier flight.
Be home a little earlier.
That was a real
intense turn around.
More, more, more.
That's my new rallying cry, DRock.
- [DRock] (laughs)
More, more, more.
- I'm really into it.
Just more, right?
More like whatever
you're doing, more.
That's what I figured out.
Actually that's what
is really populating
to my head is
more, more, more.
It's like work-life
balance, great, more.
Spend more time with the family.
Like meditation, great. More.
Like wanting to rule
and dominate the game, more.
Like whatever it is
it's just more, more, more.
That's my advice actually.
That captures my advice.
Like make the fucking
t-shirt right now.
You hit up the team,
that's what I want,
#MoreMoreMore.
- [DRock] Okay.
- Dude's pants
are fucking awesome.
More, more, more.
(DRock laughs)
("Warhols" by Truth City)
We're speaking now because what
we've been doing with him,
the amount of people that follow
me that do what you guys do when
it was the wine
thing, that's one thing.
Basically all the vloggers and
all these individuals that are
producing content
through camera form online,
the people that follow
us and him for that reason,
there's probably something very
intriguing that we should have a
conversation about.
- Absolutely.
- That's why
came to follow you.
- Is that right?
- We do.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] Have a
safe flight. Stay well.
- Pleasure meeting you.
("Warhols" by Truth City)
DRock just threw
this on me 'cause he
said I needed to do a
hey, goodnight close out scene.
No. See ya.
That's DRock in the back.
Instagram, what up?
Done with my commute to,
went to San Francisco
for an hour.
We really went to
San Francisco for an hour.
- [DRock] I know.
- 3,000 peeps in here, DRock.
Uh-huh, not too shabby.
Yeah, Deisnuts.
De Simone was busy.
I was in three
hours hitting up random
people giving away t-shirts.
Like make sure you're part of
the 60 Second Club 'cause I was
just going through three hours
of anybody who left a comment
just DM'ing random
people saying hello.
- [DRock] Yeah?
- Peeps were super pumped.
Guy's taking a
selfie with Shake Shack.
I love it.
That's some good
content right there.
Never baby.
24/7/365 that's how I do it.
- Can you stop working, man?
- Nope 24/7, that's my number.
Dunk, good to see you.
Would you fire me if I
put a picture of Brady
over your office tomorrow?
Yes, Dunk I would.
In a heartbeat by the way, too.
Like no hesitation.
Like happily.
Take care.
Dunk, I get it man.
You're more than capable
to go do it on yourself.
Be a good way to
get fired, I agree.
That'd be good,
good, good content.
What else is going on here?
I'm a Jets fan,
who lives in Atlanta.
Dan, that's the worst.
My sneaks.
Went with some good ones today.
The white on green.
You know I wore the
white on green today?
- [DRock] Nope.
- 'Cause those
are my Jets sneakers.
That's just what
I wanted to do today.
It was a crazy day.
Did you guys follow
the narrative today?
Did you guys see, did
you guys see what the fuck
I was up to today?
Commuted to
San Francisco for an hour.
You ever think you
were gonna do that, DRock?
- [DRock] Nope. Never did.
- [Gary] The wake up at 4 A.M.
to spend an hour in
San Francisco and be back.
We have Ontario this week.
- [DRock] I know.
- [Gary] Little Canadian love.
Looking forward to that.
Oh, and your best friend
Casey is gonna be there.
- [DRock] At there?
- [Gary] Yeah, Casey's
speaking at that event.
Love you, see ya.
Keep grinding.
Gonna try to do
more live sessions.
That was fun.
My arm's tired though
and I've been working out.
Alright, now I'm
saying an official goodbye.
Goodbye, I love you.